today's guest is Antonia Bogdanovich
daughter of film legends Peter
Bogdanovich and the late Polly Platt
Antonia makes her film directorial debut
with my left-hand man let's talk about
my left-hand man it follows the
theatrical and dysfunctional Emerson
family with two teenage sons and an
addicted father a has-been thespian of
the two brothers one performs
Shakespeare for trusting strangers while
the other pics the crowds pockets we are
honored to welcome to film courage
Antonia plug donavah ch welcome thank
you it's great to have you thank you for
having me awesome absolutely I would
also like to thank Cynthia stefanoni for
helping us arrange this conversation
loves everyone and for everyone
listening you guys you can get a closer
look at Antonia's work by visiting
station eight films com and she's on
Twitter you can connect with her at
Tonya 2000 not a lot of guests on the
show have grown up on movie sets can you
tell us about your childhood yes um well
I think my mother probably was pregnant
on targets no she walks by with me in
her arms and targets so you can see a
little clip of me so that's the first
time I was on the movie sad i was
probably maybe a week or two old and I
really probably didn't understand what a
movie set was it was just where my
parents worked when i first started
realizing what kind of maybe that I was
a little different I was about six and a
half and I was driving on Sunset
Boulevard with my mother and I looked up
and there was a billboard of Barbra
Streisand and I said mom what's Barbara
doing up there so I mean I had no idea
and she explained she's and it was there
was a big gold record next to it and
she's a well honey barbara as a singer
you know she's not only an actress but
she sings and she's she's a huge singer
and I was like oh and then of course a
few years later I realized like okay you
know so that's that's a little bit of
like you just don't realize that you're
any different from anyone
because this is just what you know hmm
so the people that you grew up around
you just knew them as who they were and
didn't really realize what an impact
they had on the world yeah and you know
the paparazzi I mean it's changed a bit
so if we were somewhere with a celebrity
I mean nobody ever came up to us and you
know and it was a lot of time spent in
homes so I didn't really we didn't
really go out to restaurants that much I
mean I went with my parents separately
you know I know there was a little bit
of stalking that went on with Cybill
Shepherd a bit in Bel Air but that was
kind of you know it just wasn't the same
when I was younger so well you've
mentioned also in a few interviews that
you were rebellious as a teenager not
that I would know anything about that I
understated that's an understatement
what did you do to defy adults I'm
curious well I I definitely was I think
a shamed of my wealth somehow i'm not
sure why by the time I was a teenager I
was quite angry at my parents for not
being around a lot and making movies and
you know the neglecting to be there um
so I I gravitated towards kids that were
all blue collar and and then we're
thieves so I think I didn't necessarily
know that they were thieves but it kind
of just it was cool you know oh they rob
houses that's cool it was only until my
own house was robbed that I realized
maybe I was you know choosing the wrong
friends but I you know I I was kind of a
street kid I didn't really like you know
I liked Venice I like the beach I spent
a lot of time outside so I and I I think
I related to kids that weren't
privileged not that the privileged kids
had it easier um my friends I could
relate to more because they had to
signal homes or you know trouble in the
home or drugs or whatever and you know I
had a lot of that so I just related to
those kids easier sure how is being a
girl rebel different from being a guy
rebel I'm sure it's much more
controversial maybe because you scare
people they don't know how to sort of
categorize you yeah well I think with a
girl rebel you have to actually be going
to fight if somebody punches you and I
definitely didn't have a problem I mean
I that's the only that's the only when
it comes to mind like I got in
fistfights in junior high school for
sure and I was never the one that
started them but if somebody punched me
in the face Oh watch out or tried to hit
me or pull my hair or whatever it was
down I mean I I got suspended for for
fighting being a girl I I think that I
had certain girlfriends that could
handle me and then I had a lot of guy
friends I think that's what happens when
you're a girl rebel is you have more
male friends hence my short is all male
and a lot of my characters and my
scripts there's great female characters
but I tend to gravitate towards male
characters and male themes and I had
sisters so the brother thing was easy to
do not easy but I love the idea of
brothers because maybe because I didn't
have I wasn't a boy and I didn't have a
brother like so and it similar two
sisters were very different mmm you know
i'm just wondering during your
upbringing were your parents you know
them both being artistic were they
supportive of your sort of artistic
abilities and creativity my father was
absolutely supportive a hundred percent
I was I started as a singer I mean that
was the first thing I can remember that
I would get out and my father was very
supportive of me being a singer or
musician my mother she wasn't supportive
in so much in the arts when I was really
young because I think she was trying to
protect me from rejection and what she
would call failure so she was very
discouraging for me to be an actress a
performer a dancer and I think some of
that probably had to do with what
happened to her in Peter and it was an
actress that split them up but I didn't
really understand that as a child so I
just figured she was right okay you know
you're never going to make it she'd say
a lot of that and that's hard because I
think when you
from another area that's not Hollywood
like the Midwest or even you know East
Coast outside of New York City you know
moms and dads if they see that our child
is talented in one area they go out go
out to Hollywood become an actress you
can do it you know and my mom had the
reality of there's hundreds of actors
out here every year thousands come you
know she'd always say to me one percent
of sag works you know and that's sticks
in your head you know did that make you
want to go after that much more um
initially yes and then it caused a lot
of insecurities because you got to be
really confident on auditions and I
think another problem I had was and my
mom was actually trying to teach me this
don't be a people pleaser don't kick
kiss ass and she was not like that um
and so I would go into auditions and try
and please and that's really the wrong
thing to do in an audition I think I
learned eventually to do it differently
and then I started getting callbacks you
know don't try and please just go and do
your thing you know just so in being
yourself as trite as that sounds but
just yeah that's the sort of the rule
and that casting directors can see
through that the asteroid yeah too eager
interesting you know there's always this
perception that that second generation
always has it easier and and you've said
that you know just because my parents
are who they are that didn't help me I
had to start from scratch I didn't have
a manager I didn't have an agent I was
using my personal contacts from my
previous work in productions to get
people to read my scripts so you know it
sounds like you've had it just as hard
as anyone listening actually I think
it's crazy I've had it harder i would
say that for sure because people are
going to not measure me by an anonymous
name they're going to look at at my
scripts or me and then they're going to
have a certain idea i don't know what
those ideas are because I'm I can't look
get outside of myself I don't know what
it's like not to be Peter or Polly's
daughter but it's interesting because I
met a great writer and a
hope to be a wonderful friend Gordon
Hoffman he's philip seymour hoffman's
brother and I didn't know when I met him
I just didn't put two and two together
and when I found out we've court have
had more to talk about and he said you
know people always think we have it
easier but we don't we have it harder
and it was so interesting to hear him
say that and then sometimes people don't
want to help you because they have a
history with Peter or Paul II and they
figure you know she's gonna be a pain or
she's not or who knows you know there's
there's a history there I think the
public will if you do something good
embrace you more and say well of course
you know and that's really who we want
is the audience to to be fans of your
work that's the whole point that's
something my mother taught me you know
it's all about the audience and the fans
you know you know that's what you're
making the movies for is to express
yourself to not to Hollywood mean that's
great but your peers yeah you want that
support but really we're trying to reach
the general public and express ourselves
artistically so yeah I think in
Hollywood it's it's harder mm-hmm it's
harder when you seem to have such an old
soul despite being young and physical
age what has been your best education
and why is it is it college is it being
on the set is it just observing people
um I one of my grandparents were
probably the biggest influence when I
was really young my grandfather was a
painter my father's father and my
grandmother was a maid the frames for
him and also was just a wonderful
European um human being just European
roots but just a wonderful human being
to us she was Jewish on on on in you
know culturally not religiously sorry I
lost my point um Oh what was my
influence so she passed away when I was
in fifth grade and I was very close with
her she was definitely a strong maternal
figure so that affected me quite a bit I
think my parents splitting up when I was
three affected me
very very deeply and I'm still trying to
come to terms with that I'm they were
inseparable until they made the last
picture show and um and they continue to
work together even after they split up
but um if you look at pictures when I
was little I was very attached to both
of them and so I think I was it well you
know it made me grow up really quickly
to have to deal with like such a
different reality so young my parents
splitting up and like just a series of
events before I was 12 and then you know
my father was a huge director in the 70s
and a lot like Tatum O'Neal we saw a lot
of things that children aren't supposed
to see she's publicly talked about it so
um you know there's it was thought that
culture back then saks and drugs and my
father never got dipped into I mean he
never had a problem with drugs but there
was drugs in the house there was you
know there was things going on that were
just fun it was fun it wasn't like bad
but sure you know and I don't think
you're supposed to my mom didn't like
that at all that that you know that was
around but I i'm happy that had happened
because it may mean person i am today I
thought it was cool you know you know
you you know your whole life you've been
so close to this business I mean you've
seen people rise to success those who
haven't risen to you know those who have
sort of fallen you know what what does
it take to succeed you know in this
business oh that's an interesting
question um you know I think that you I
think the thing I've seen a lot is you
have to continue to live in the real
world and that's really hard when you
get successful but if you have even a
place outside of Los Angeles where you
can go and just mix among the populace
so you you kind of know what's going on
like the pulse of the nation but I also
think you have to work from a place to
you know inside as an artist and express
yourself but
I think you know it I mean it depends on
what you define success as box office
success or just successes oh I made a
film that I'm really proud of I think
you know as long as your stay true to
your vision of what you started out as a
filmmaker sometimes that's hard though
because there's you know the bigger you
get the more difficult it is to actually
make those artistic decisions by
yourself so you know as long as you're
staying true to your vision and I think
if you have a great script to start out
with and it's solid script that you
believe in I think that helps that's
interesting so so in order to have sort
of this balance and maintain in this
industry you're saying that maybe
there's a place that someone should go
where they're just anonymous where
people don't need anything from them and
they can just kind of be among the
people and yeah I mean I think Wes
Anderson has really done this amazingly
well I mean he are all his movies you
feel like those are real people you know
like these are and and you know he'd I
don't think he lives in Los Angeles I
think he spends a lot of time in Paris
um yeah I mean because movies ultimately
are about the human condition right even
even as you know all the great movies
that are science fiction or horror
they're they're still about people you
know it so when you stop really making
it about people that you go and all this
doesn't really ring true to me so if you
are not friends with people that are
outside the film business or you don't
you know congregate with them how are
you supposed to know I don't know you
have to just keep keep meeting people
and getting to know different you're
different characters and in terms to of
sort of preserving one's mental health
do you think that's important as well
because you can go and it's not about
competition and it's not about anybody's
ego and then just go and just be yeah an
ego is the thing that really destroys
people in this business I mean I think I
mean if you if you can't step outside
your ego and say the
isn't any good i need to change it i
need to edit it i need to rewrite it i
need to recut it i mean that's that's
gonna that's the hardest thing with with
being a celebrity or tsuge lee
successful as the ego gets i mean it's
it's very complicated and i can't really
comment because i haven't been there but
not truly comment but to yeah i mean i
think it's really important to be able
to judge be objective hmm well in
another interview that you did you
mentioned lady macbeth and you said
something fascinating and you said it's
the classic struggle all powerful women
face sometimes we have to act like men
and repress our female side to get what
we want or gain power but then after we
have that power and get what we want we
often suffer because we are women and we
feel sort of this intense maybe guilt or
we reflect on what we've done and then
we feel badly so how is this struggle
both for powerful women in front of the
camera and behind sort of different as
far as i can only comment really on
being behind the camera now because
that's where I'm at in my life I'm sure
it's I mean we have to deal with a lot
more sexual innuendos all the time as a
female and you kind of have to get past
that sometimes too with certain people
for them to take you seriously or you
have to kind of play with that dance
with that for people to take you
seriously or to actually listen what you
have to say as opposed to the flirtation
but I do think we as women filmmakers
have to be strong producers writers
directors actresses because it's we have
to be strong because we have that to
contend with because ultimately I still
think were a minority as women in the
world I mean as females we don't rule
you know we don't rule all the countries
and I think it's so yeah I think that we
have to and then we do feel guilty
x and we oftentimes if we have children
we have to leave them at home which I'm
struggling with now to you know to have
a career it reminds me of the notorious
bettie page with Gretchen mall and hear
her sexuality gets her foot in the door
but then it's also the thing that kind
of holds her back I always found that
fascinating so how can women work around
that how can we be powerful and in
charge without getting the b-word
slapped on us well maybe we wanted that
you know sometimes I feel like yeah
that's that's a really interesting
question because sometimes I'll be
having a conversation with a man and
I'll want to say something really honest
which would be probably construed as
and I don't and then I walk away
and I'm like you know remember what your
mother taught you don't be a kiss-ass
and it's not that I'm kissing somebody's
butt but I'm not really being honest
like with them and that's hard sometimes
you know to have to you know I think you
learn as you get especially when you're
working on a film and you're
collaborating it's a little different
than pounding the pavement I mean I hope
to get to that place where I'm actually
just working with people in
pre-production in development in
production and it's we're working the
building up to that and then selling
yourself and doing all that stuff a deer
has to be a dance that you play to get
in the room quote unquote you know
hopefully your scripts in your project
speak for themselves but you still have
to do the dance interesting you know I
Tony you know you had so much exposure
to well known people to famous people
actors filmmakers you know from what fun
you know you know not everyone has that
sort of exposure to the people that
you've had exposure to would you say at
the heart of it I mean I mean how much
of it at the heart of it is them seeking
Fame you know because you know you
mentioned sort of the ego come to play
how much of it is them seeking Fame and
how much is it is is them just staying
focused on the work and going after work
is there some sort of line there's or
anything you can just I don't understand
like yeah yeah well i think that the
the actors and at when I was younger we
didn't call them celebrities but actors
well-known actors the ones that my
parents tended to work with and I don't
think this was accidental were
definitely major artists all of them and
I think you know I was an actress and so
I can say this i mean actors and I not
and i am still this way we're filled
with insecurities so to a certain extent
fame makes you I temporarily take that
away but I think sometimes it makes you
more insecure I mean you i'm not sure i
just know that you know we like to be
praised if we're artists we like to be
praised but you know there has to be
something inside that's filling the void
besides being praised for your art you
have to have you have to feel like
you're doing the art for yourself so I
most of the actors like John Ritter and
Jack Nicholson and Shirley MacLaine the
ones that I remember really spending a
lot of time when actually working in
production with them you know as a
production assistant were quite but you
know they were great they had
interesting stories to tell I didn't
really see so much how the fame had
affected them but I again I was like an
isolated environment a set of so
enclosed and like let's like a family so
I didn't really see them out and about I
know that a lot of those times if I was
with a celebrity on the street and
somebody would come in ask for an
autograph they were gracious very
gracious about it you know my father
included you know there are those of us
who only see ourselves as actors or
filmmakers or screenwriters and we
cannot see ourselves doing anything else
you know but if for some reason that
time comes where we have to walk away
from this career you know what thoughts
are lessons can you share with us you
know whether they be spiritual or just
simply lessons you've learned in your
life
well I walked away from this career as
an actress and I swore I'd never come
back my heart was broken at the time I'm
I probably was going through a midlife
crisis although I was kind of young in
my 20s I I started hating the business
for everything that it wasn't I know
that sounds kind of strange for
everything that wasn't the movie set and
making a movie because that's a
beautiful thing it can be and I've
worked on some movies that are like
disastrously hard but it's it was the
you know the the political part about
being an actress and not getting parts
we for certain looks and certain you
know physical traits so and then kind of
seeing what happened to my father his
ups and downs and what happened to my
mother she was very successful but she
had a tortured personal life I was like
I don't want end up like that so when
you do walk away you have to have
something else that you are passionate
about or you're thinking about something
else you have to have something a la
bonne too but then sometimes it's it's a
period of time like I needed to take the
time to develop as a writer in another
genre completely journalist to realize
that this is really my calling and that
and I fought it hard I fought against it
so my encases a little differently but I
think you have to have something else if
you're gonna walk away because this is
so exciting you know but by the time I
left it wasn't that long but I had been
working in film for so long that it felt
like a very long time you have to be
willing to say I don't need that
adrenaline rush I don't you know but
I've realized now that there is nothing
as fulfilling and interesting as making
films and I never thought I'd say that
again I remember watching an interview
with Burt Reynolds just real quick doing
research for this and he talked about
something fascinating called the enemy
effect I believe maybe I'm not
paraphrasing it right but your dad was
interviewing him
and Bert was saying that there's
something in this town where if you rise
too fast without paying your dues
there's almost this jealousy that occurs
within the industry and almost tries
collectively to hold you back do you
think that still exists today that was
an old interview now with YouTube with
social media and people being able to
take things in their own hands do you
think that it's almost the flip side you
know American Idol can sort of launched
someone overnight or do you think that
still exists that whole sort of if I'm
saying that correctly the enemy barrier
the enemy the enemy factor very
interesting Bert said that definitely
happen to my father at least that's what
he told me you know growing up by the
time you know nineteen eighty nineteen
eighty one came around you know he'd
seen his star was falling at that time
um but uh yeah I mean I think I think
that yeah people get jealous I think
it's very competitive I've never been
really a jealous person but I can
understand it I'm more competitive with
myself but yeah I mean I think I think
it's hard for some people maybe they
want to keep you down or maybe they're
intimidated by your brilliance your
genius i mean not mine i'm talking about
my father's um yeah I mean I I don't
think it's as much anymore no no I think
and I think that's it's funny you
mention American Idol I mean I love that
show because the public votes like so
that's the all I mean that's like the
box office doesn't lie you know here you
are these are what the people are going
to see it's a lot of word of mouth but
you know the populace is voting in these
these superstar that becomes superstars
you know like Kelly Clarkson and I mean
I love her you know to name a few well
just going back real quickly to your
being an actor I think you had mentioned
in another interview that you had stage
fright and coming to peace with the
terms that you just didn't really want
to act anymore do you remember that
epiphany do you remember when that
happened when you said you know what I
think this is it
for the acting well um yeah I was a
terrible auditioner because I didn't
grow up auditioning I grew up on movie
sets so you cannot get me on a movie set
and I'm completely relaxed I can do my
work and do the lines I can what do you
need I'll deliver it um yeah but on
stage singing was hard for me because of
stage fright I found out my grandfather
had terrible stage fright he was a
concert pianist and he could never
perform in front of people so he hence
didn't really achieve you know that
level of but um I think it's more
recently because I came back as a writer
and then I decided I wanted to try
directing and I started in the theater
so a couple people said you know walk
walk by you know when I was shooting a
short walk by the camera do a Hitchcock
and I said no I'll do something else
that you know eventually develop where
you know i'm i'm putting my stamp on it
maybe it's just going to be the visual
and the writing and the acting but um
you know I think it was late you know
when I close to the time I quit acting
the auditioning was just a bear for me
you know you've known JJ Abrams for many
many years you know you said you've
known him i guess 25 plus years what
makes him such a unique talent you know
could you have ever imagined this sort
of career path for him I mean did you
did you envision this happening and it
was there something you saw early on I
said you know what I think um you know
just you know I got you know did you
ever envision this sort of career
pathways my mother did I'm gonna give
her that credit I'll give her lots of
credit but mom oh yeah she was working
with him on the second floor of the
Sidney Poitier building and I was on the
third floor editing a film for a couple
of years I'll do anything and they were
on the second floor and JJ had a
development deal and you know there was
a lot of down time with the editing and
then JJ was writing his screenplay which
became which was called all four years
it became felicity eventually but uh my
mother saw it and she
talk about him all the time and then I
became very good friends with him
separate from my mother and we would
hang out all the time and he was he was
quick he was smart he was funny
hysterical but really a unique
personality and really driven and very
energetic and my mother just kept
talking about his talent so no I'm
actually not surprised he's a super hard
worker and incredibly down to earth you
know I didn't see him for a long time
because I I moved away and I was out of
the business and when I did see him
again we were having this like banter
and I'm like you haven't changed a bit
and he's like either of you but I was
expecting him to be different I mean I
was like expecting him to be completely
different but he's not at all and and
he's been so incredibly supportive of my
work and you know it just amazing I mean
I'm just it it still surprises me
because I'm expecting that he would be
different he's still that down to earth
enthusiastic you know just of everybody
that he's working with and everybody
that he works with at bad robot they're
incredible he hosted a screening of my
short I mean it was like amazing they
had like you know appetizers and drinks
I mean I just felt like it was like
first-class service I was like I was so
honored I was so honored we are in
studio with filmmaker Antonio
Bogdanovich her film left hand man
screens at the buffalo-niagara film
festival April fifteenth at 5pm so
anyone in that area you got to get out
and see it and then also at the Memphis
International Film Festival film and
music festival excuse me April
nineteenth through the 22nd let's talk
about my left-hand man in your
directorial film debut because you've
directed some stage right yeah so film
just a few things on the stage oh I mean
it was amateur too I mean I don't want
to I don't want to put forth that it was
like a big big production it was a you
know in a small small area in Sacramento
with you know nan you know professional
actors which was actually really great
because I had to you know so making that
lead
making that jump you know from from
stage and then you said you resisted
this for a long time why did you have to
make this film um well I think I made
the short 22 people started asking me
when they read my scripts do you want to
be a director and I always thought the
question how to do with my father or my
mother and I would say well I've thought
about it I've directed some theater and
I really enjoyed it and the productions
were quite successful in my opinion and
the actors are very happy why are you
asking and they said because your
scripts read like a director wrote them
and I said really and I said what do you
mean lots all visual everything's visual
the stage direction that is that on top
of the fact that they liked the script
they commented on that so I started
singing hmm and then and so then I
thought well let me see if I like it so
let me write a short now that was the
hardest thing I've ever had to do
because I've never written a short and
I've always read read scripts written
features and watched quite a few movies
quite a few so and I really haven't
watched that many shorts there's really
not a lot of you know places you can see
a short so that was hard and I did it to
discover if I liked directing because
you can't really say if you want to
direct film if you haven't done it I now
watch my father do it i watch many many
directors work but it's different when
you're the you're the you know actually
doing it yourself well you mentioned in
a prior interview that you're obsessive
and detailed about your writing I think
you said to your parents were as well
and and that goes back to that whole ego
thing because on the flip side we can
have two little ego and be too hard on
ourselves does that ever happen to you
where you hold yourself back because
you're too critical of your writing or
no I'm know you did it used to happen
when I was writing prose when I stepped
into screenwriting I was like oh okay
because I'd been writing in other genres
for a long time and then the script
writing came so easily I was like oh I'm
not saying I wasn't critical of it but I
knew it was for the first time
my life I knew it was actually good what
I was writing and I learned by reading a
lot of books about being a writer you
really shouldn't analyze your work and
still you have like a solid fifth sixth
seventh eighth draft so I never
criticize my first draft first drafts
are all sorry Bella leave you get
here Dave some time lately I have to
doesn't cut them off yeah I mean first
drafts my father taught me writing both
my parents writing is rewriting I mean I
can't tell you how true that is I cannot
tell you I did 18 drafts on my first my
second screenplay my first screenplay I
actually wrote when I was 27 I put that
aside and I never did anything with it
but the second screenplay that I was
really serious about 17 drafts 18 drafts
to get it right and the notes from
colleagues notes from my mother and
father which were amazing so that's how
you get through it instead of just a
side yeah and then you get really good
feedback from other people but I knew
look I know good a good film if you know
how to read a screenplay and you can see
everything which is how I write I see
the scene um you know it's going to work
I mean that's my editing background
construction came easy to me because of
all the editing so I knew like when to
stop a scene which seemed to go to next
you know construction very important to
restructure mm-hmm well then you
mentioned another interview that while
you were shooting my left-hand man or
maybe afterward that you had this moment
where you looked up at the sky and you
said okay this is it I was meant to do
this and you talk about that that night
or that day oh yeah um yeah I Thomas
Sangster is an amazing actor he's like
he like took my breath away and we were
shooting it was late night and he did
something some take up take of something
that was so I hadn't even given him much
direction and he like blew it out of the
water and and I'm not I don't like to be
emotional in front of people I mean that
comes from having a lot of trauma you in
your life when you're
young you just you want to get away when
you're hurt so or crying so I I was knew
i was going to tear up and I started to
I'm like yours I've been around actors
my whole life and you're amazing and I
walked out and I looked up at the sky
and I said you know I was crying and I
said thank God I found it now before it
was too late that this is you know what
I'm supposed to be doing I know how to
talk to actors oh my god I relate to
them because I was what like it was like
it was like a million like connections
and the synapses in my brain going whoa
it's like I found home how I was this so
difficult to find home when I started
here but I didn't start on movie sets
where I ended up right and I wasn't a
director I was always working for
somebody else and I paid my dues i
schlepped I got water I got cigarettes i
got lunches I mean I did it all um you
know I you know paid my dues so to be
yeah so I yeah I was like wow I'm glad I
found discovered it on this short film
that this is what I'm supposed to be and
I was very strong strong and how does
that how does that make you feel today
that you've come to this epiphany well
it makes me feel happy very happy and it
keeps me going on the challenge now is
going to be you know making my first
feature which is hard for anybody um
that's the you know I'm hopefully going
to do another short just to keep going
just to keep directing on a small one
you know maybe two days shoot so I you
know I have to keep using the instrument
so I'm writing all the time but that's
going to be the real challenge it feels
great oh I have a purpose and and and
I'm going to go for it i have been going
for it I mean is this literally sort of
the first time in your life where you
feel like now I finally have a purpose I
mean have you felt this previously well
I I've always wanted to be a writer I
mean I started writing poetry when I was
18 so it was poetry for a long time and
then it was short stories and then it
was pros and journalism so
but yeah I mean it feels it no it's it's
probably the first time I felt this way
and it's been going on for since I in
the middle of shooting a short I mean I
had I was actually wanted to direct
about a year before that and I mean you
can't just snap your fingers and I
actually was frightened to tell my
father that I wanted to do what he did
um I I knew he would I wasn't sure if he
was going to be encouraging although
he's always been encouraging it was just
so weird to go dad I want to be a
director cuz it's just you know it's
intimidating sure to but he was like
when I told him he was like well of
course I mean you mean he was like it
was like a no-brainer for him you'd be
great is what he said I don't know why I
think he would say something else you
know it's not the relationship we've
ever had he's always been encouraging
but you know I think that people
surprise you and that's the wonderful
thing about relationships so I wasn't
sure how he was going to her act so I
didn't until I admitted it to him I
really didn't want to admit it to
anybody else I mean a lot of people
follow in their parents footsteps a lot
of you know people a lot of doctors that
you're their sons and daughters become
doctors I don't know why I was such an I
think it's the whole mysticism and you
know magic about the film business that
made me like I don't know insecurities
is sure well I'm sure there's a lot of
pressure to you know just to yeah I'm
sure that pressure is is probably be
very difficult to deal with how did you
go about securing financing haha i
financed it myself okay was my it was my
pretty much my life savings and but it's
well worth it and it definitely went
over budget you know because we have you
know it's an action a bit of an action
movie so you got a little bit of special
effects and you know costs went up from
being on days that I remember seeing
Roger Corman speak at the LA Film
Festival and they were talking about how
he would just cut things down and
just remember although that I may I
can't remember the specifics but the
different tips were there things that
jog your memory from being on the set
where know this is going to take too
long this is going to waste time and
let's just move on well I definitely
work quickly I got that from my dad um
you know and I also was lucky enough to
have actors that I didn't have to do
multiple takes but we didn't really have
time to do really over ten takes um I
think on my next film if well I'm not
going to finance another shorter than
the short that I plan on doing is going
to be like low-budget nobody's getting
paid I mean I hate everybody on this
short I really felt like now but now I
have a group of people i think that
would come together just for a day and
do something this was a four day shoot
um you i mean we tried to make two
locations so there's yeah there's
definitely a few things that I knew I
had to do as for in the writing to make
it work in the budget post-reduction
cost a lot more than I thought so I
learned a lot about you know absolutely
when I called in a lot of favors you
know but would pretty much paid for
everything you know with discounts karma
credit karma credit yeah and and can you
talk specifically maybe there's some
examples that you've learned from your
father you know you've said that you
know your father taught you how to talk
to actors about where to put the camera
and why can you speak a little bit about
that what you learned for your father in
terms of how he spoke to actors and and
what you learned in terms of placing the
camera well my father taught me um he
you know I think that it's very personal
how you talk to actors I couldn't ever
talk to an act or the way my father does
he has like an amazing gift but I I'm
going to develop mine for further but um
he was an actor so we understand where
the actor is coming from really you have
to encourage your actors even if you
don't like what they're doing or it's
not right for where you're going because
you have the vision of the whole film
right so if they do a take and it's
really not what you're looking for you
don't you don't discourage it you say
that was great or
you know always give them support my dad
taught me that and he learned that from
stella a lot of how to talk to actors
from stella adler his his work there as
far as where to put the camera um I've
watched I watched hundreds and hundreds
of films before I was ten we weren't
allowed to walk to television at my
father's house we were only allowed to
watch movies and he had a collection of
you know not DVDs but they were on tape
and we could watch those so you know as
a kid you want to watch something you
know TV or something so we'd put on a
movie and then he had a screening room
so I learned a lot from Orson Welles and
Hitchcock and John Ford and you know
Frank Capra and and Renoir I'm and then
from my own father yeah he the camera
has to be another at the visual has to
be a part of telling the story so where
you put that camera in a room or outside
a room has to benefit the telling of the
story in a visual way that's the best
way I can put it but I think he taught
me a lot that it would be hard to
articulate you know now are you planning
to turn my left-hand man into a feature
or you also working on another feature
I'm yes I'm I'm I'm writing a thriller
based on my left-hand man about
counterfeiting it won't be called my
left-hand man it might be called the
Cardinal comet which is one of the comic
character we had to create in my left
hand man because we weren't allowed to
use any DC comic characters um but it's
about counterfeiting I'm writing that
but my first feature i'd love to be a
script that I happen to find in my in a
drawer it was collecting dust it was in
a pile of my father scripts and I got to
the bottom of the pile I had heard of
all the other scripts you know the
titles I knew the last script on the
bottom of the pile said the title of the
script and then it said by Peter
Bogdanovich and Polly Platt
and I said what what's this and it would
you know so I opened it up and it starts
and the kind it was after you know five
pages of reading five pages i was
completely into it and it was having to
be in the genre that I'm the direction
of where I'm going thrillers crime some
you know it's about World War two on the
eve of Hitler invading Poland and it's
it's gritty it's it's amazing story the
characters amazing it's of course about
four men not of course but again my
interest is so I'm completely blown away
by it and we are developing now doing
with my managers trying to get it set up
and and I it's a beautiful thing that
they wrote this in 1968 that's why we've
been updating and polishing the script
because it you know it was written a
long time ago and they wrote it after
they done targets it's probably one of
the few scripts that they wrote together
that was not made into a feature so it's
it's it's basically a very looks like a
Hollywood gem I mean really wow it's
like a little piece of history that I
found in a drawer and when was this in
December some and I mean I called my dad
and I was like you know I didn't know
anything about it and then my sister
Shashi she'd read it and years ago and
she was loved it and was very interested
in directing it herself so um so it's a
and my father has told me that he would
he's totally supportive in me directing
this because he owns the script and he
would produce it like funny he one
capsule yeah he will produce it if if if
it all comes together he's willing to do
that alright cool we love it we love it
wow that's been it's been just wonderful
just sitting back and just listening to
the richness you know like just your
history it just there's so much there
Tony we're just so grateful that you
would come the studio with no cheese
it's my pleasure yeah this is one I'm
kind of speechless just I mean I was
just sad no I was transported yes you
were telling me these stories and um
yeah thank you so much that's nice thank
you so much
really really enriching you know we've
been speaking with filmmaker and Tony
about Bogdanovich for more on Antonio
please visit her website station eight
films com we mentioned you can follow
her on Twitter Tonya two thousand and
she you can find all their credits and
everything else on IMDb and be sure to
visit the sites of the memphis
international film and music festival
and the buffalo-niagara film festival
where the short my left-hand man will be
screening in april history yes both of
them are in april okay and hopefully
we'll get into a few more festival this
year fingers crossed okay very cool yeah
alright well thank you again for joining
us and look forward to seeing if the
left-hand man is that are my left-hand
man is turned into a feature and also
this a special project thank you and she
and she just released the trailer online
so be sure to check that out as well you
know I know we posted on Facebook well
what will have it will have it you know
for those of you who go to our film cars
com will have it with the interview so
you able to see the trailer they're
stunning cinematography excellent acting
you definitely want to take a closer
look beautiful and that does it for us
folks until next Sunday have a great
week